what's going on guys this is Rob and
this Indie comic is one of the coolest
Indie Comics that I've read in recent
memory it was written by Morris critical
it's called God slap so there are two
things to know number one because this
is a crowd-funded comic there will be a
link down in the description so you guys
can contribute to the campaign so that
this comic can actually reach like full
production and two I will be offering my
my thoughts and little critiques and so
on but one of the best things about this
comic right is that it's not a
traditional Western comic like
Spider-Man Captain America Batman
Superman it's not really like that it
really has this kind of vibe where it's
like comic books meet manga which is
really awesome because even when you
look at like the release trailer for it
it feels like an anime right so it's
just it's a it's a really really cool
thing so what this does here is this
initially picks up at a nightclub right
Elder Swan is kind of what this place is
called now the overall setting for this
environment isn't a place called
Montpelier which if I'm being honest
with you guys it really feels more like
Neo Tokyo from like Akira back in 1988
those you guys who are familiar with
that akita's kind of like a kind of like
a landmark anime that was one of those
that just sort of brought it to a much
larger audience than it previously been
done uh it was based on a 1982 manga of
the same name but it's just one of those
like classic iconic pieces of work that
exist out there in the world this feels
a lot like that right so while it's not
necessarily called Neo Tokyo it really
has that kind of cyberpunk aesthetic to
it so of course in this nightclub you
basically have a guy who's just being a
dick to what looks like a waitress or a
dancer or something like that this guy
goes he basically gets his drink he goes
to goes to drink it and of course
somebody out here makes it his last one
because this guy takes one to the Dome
piece now the thing about this is that
this introduces us to a guy by the name
of Darius now this is where the kind of
anime slash manga feels come into play
and that's one of the things that I kind
of had to adjust to initially I was
going into this reading it like I would
a Spider-Man comic or Batman comic or
Superman comic but once you sort of cast
that that idea aside and you actually
start reading it more like a manga or an
anime it totally changes the way that
you see it and that's what makes it so
awesome because as you guys know or
those of you guys who are fans of anime
and manga they really kind of leans
itself more towards like over the top
just some wild crazy stuff even the
names and like the stories themselves
are kind of crazy like the devil has a
part-time job but the thing about this
is that Darius is given to us as this
guy who possesses something that's
called the god slap now again the cool
thing about this is we're given a
display of what this guy can do when of
course these guards kind of run out of
nowhere and they're like put your hands
up you know that kind of thing he
literally throws his coat and then uses
his God slap to slap these guys to death
like he just like slaps the guy's head
in half it's just amazing right then
like he takes the other guys out they
start shooting at him so like he uses
the god slap to like slap the bullets
away it's dope
I love the way this is done here's a
question those of you guys who read
[ __ ] or watch anime while I am kind of
getting into it I know there are a lot
of you who are like super hardcore when
it comes to that stuff is this the kind
of stuff you get in anime and manga
because if it is I'm gonna read and
watch more of that stuff man food Wars
is really cool that's the other one that
I'm watching as well but one of the
things this guy does right like Darius
does is with all these different video
cameras here he actually flicks the
camera which in turn takes the camera
out and nobody can see any of the
cameras and so what this looks like here
is the nature behind the god slap it
feels more like a telekinetic based
power and if that's the case it's a
genius move by morse critical because
what it does is it takes a power that we
as traditional Western comic book fans
are wildly familiar with and then it
kind of modifies it a little bit and
presents it in a different way that's
more in line with what you would see
with a manga right so it's just a great
way to blend these two themes together
of course once this camera is taken out
everybody starts freaking the hell out
and then of course these guys heads
start exploding right like just start
start busting apart and it's cool
because all you really have left is
Darius and this other guy now of course
this guy's referred to us as Sal and
we're not really given a whole lot of
information about this guy instead what
it looks like just by virtue of
statements right like literally Darius
says you know got a cigarette and I
could borrow Sal you know for old time's
sake there's obviously history here
between them now of course Sal respawns
is saying like I could have had you
killed and he even goes as far as to say
they wanted you dead I let you walk away
now Darius for the most part just kind
of responds in a way where Sal's fate is
sealed right he's like I need a light
cell and that's the thing is because of
course what we're used to with these
kind of conversations is it's like Sal
begging for his life and it's Darius
like okay man tell me what's going on
and that's sort of parlay right that
little bit of an olive branch is kind of
an indication of like Sal has a way out
the conversation here is that there is
no way out right like Sal's done like
it's curtains and so of course Sal
responds is saying like please Darius
like you must understand if you kill me
they'll know and you'll never be safe
again you or the boy you have to know
that and of course the response to this
is that where Sal says that like the boy
quote unquote his blood is Tainted that
Darius doesn't really care that Darius
takes this guy out right he kills this
guy on the spot now here's one of the
issues that I have here in terms of of
the writing of the comic so it feels a
little too formal right it feels like a
little too formal in terms of the
writing like Darius please you must
understand you know that kind of thing
like to add a little bit of character I
probably would have changed it up like
Darius you have to understand because by
speaking so formally in such a high
dearest situation it takes away from the
stress of the situation literally Sal's
life is on the line This Guy's about to
die I have a hard time believing that if
a person had a gun to my head that I
would say you must understand unless
we're talking about uh the scene from
Miller's Crossing when John Turturro
begs for his life you know what I'm
talking about look into your heart like
unless we're talking about that this
kind of it just it feels a little off
right it just it seems to kind of take
me away from how dire this situation is
for cell and so again the cool thing
about the the boy that they're referring
to when Sal asked the question like is
this kid really worth your life the
response of Darius is yes right he
absolutely is he is worth my life he's
worth your life it doesn't matter how
many have to die as long as as now this
is a cool concept because what it does
is it brings in the classic theme which
is to say there's the main guy who's
really really powerful then there's the
kid he's protecting now on the surface
it seems pretty basic but the reality
here is that again this is a genius move
by most critical because instead of
providing this just ridiculously over
overly complex plot it kind of brings us
back down to like a more basic level of
Storytelling which in truth in the 20
something years that I've been reading
comics that's the best kind of story to
tell the best kind of story to tell is
one where you can craft a story
revolving around characters that you
find to be interesting and intriguing
but it's not so ridiculously complex a
really good example of this is Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
right like that was story that in terms
of all the events going on had a massive
level of complexity but that complexity
Was Made Simple by the fact that we knew
who the characters were that if you've
been reading Marvel Comics for the last
five years you knew who all those
characters were and for the new ones who
were being introduced you got a pretty
simple origin story that wasn't overly
complex for them so if anything the
complexity of that story followed the
idea of trying to understand everything
that was going on and keeping track of
all of the events which of course was
geniusly Consolidated when you got to
the eight months later time skip but
what most critical is doing here is that
he's not giving us a ton of characters
he's building up a kind of classic plot
which again is the guy who's powerful
and the kid that he's protecting now of
course the relationship between the two
seems more strained than anything else
these two do seemingly share the same
last name that you've got Darius Braun
and you've got as bronze so they seem to
be brothers but we're not really given a
direct indication that that's the case
that seemingly the word brother isn't
really mentioned between the two of them
or at least even between the
conversations that Darius has with
anybody and so the thing about this is
that this kid is just kind of out there
and just sort of doing just laborious
work but it seems more predicated on the
idea of keeping him removed from
Montpellier so no one knows he exists
but again one of the issues that I have
here is that where Darius says like stay
away from Montpellier you know finish
putting this fence together that as
basically takes off now the the reason
why I have a little bit of of an issue
with this is because we don't really
have any development for as we don't
really know the relationship between the
two that instead as is kind of given to
us as more of like a rebellious younger
person the one who's like you can't tell
me what to do or my curiosity gets the
better of me so I'm just gonna go out
there and explore it but there's not a
whole lot to go on here I think that
before we got to A Moment Like This
where as just leaves and races off to
Montpelier I think that there should
have been a little more Exposition in
terms of the history between the two
that kind of thing right because the
only real explanation that we're given
is that he asked Darius like how is
Montpelier earlier get the supplies we
needed Darius says like Spice Shop was
boarded up and then Aya says well I
could go in for the night and scrounge
up Hearts Darius says no as says I'll be
careful Darius says I'm serious stay
away from Montpellier finish the fence
as races off so again we're not really
given a whole lot of of History here or
an understanding I mean obviously this
points to the idea that the kid kind of
has his own independent streak but I
feel like a little more work could have
been done here but the thing about this
is at this point we're basically
transitioned over to a doctor who
basically looks like William H Macy now
the entire basis behind this guy is
explained at the beginning of the issue
really in just kind of like a text box
and what it tells us is that his wife
had succumbed to an unknown blood
disease and so ever since then he's
basically been testing various people's
blood for just anomalies right something
that he is in particular looking for now
we don't know exactly what this is and
in fact an alarm goes off because an
anomaly was detected when he basically
asked his assistant right his robotic
assistant what happened that he's kind
of given these readouts and then looking
at these readouts realizes that somebody
out there or someone has done something
that is basically everything they've
been looking for right this one
particular person now all arrows or all
fingers seem to point to Darius I would
go as far as to say it's most likely as
but at the end this guy basically says
that whatever this is whoever this
person is that this will basically
change our world forever for better or
worse and so again kind of noticing the
the some of the things that we're seeing
is there's characters who are being
introduced there's motivations that are
being introduced but they're kind of
being done in a relatively simplistic
way that would require a little more
expansion in order to give a little more
gravitas and a little more meaning so
something that I want to specify here is
that these criticisms that I'm offering
I mean this is me kind of hair splitting
these are not like major issues right
it's not like we have just this
disjointed plot and it makes sense to
nobody but most critical himself that's
not the kind of issue that we're talking
about here right I mean these are just
kind of me splitting hairs the story is
fantastic
it's really cool it's just little things
that I've never notice they kind of add
to the to the story in a larger way but
the other reason why I think he's doing
this is of course the classic idea of
building these characters up giving a
reason giving us a reason to be
interested in them like what's the idea
behind Cyril what's going on with as
what the hell is the god slap just that
kind of stuff and then of course
explaining those in future stories so I
think this is one of those instances
where we kind of have to remove
ourselves from like you know a standard
Marvel and DC stories where we know who
those characters are and what they're
about and so we don't really have to
worry about familiarizing ourselves with
like their whole stories in the universe
and everything like that so again you
know it's just kind of the nature of
reading an indie comic but of course as
Aus is making his way through
Montpellier he's immediately set upon by
Scrappers now this is the cool thing
about as right this is when we start to
get a little bit more about what's going
on with them that what ends up happening
is these Scrappers are are literally
just kind of the the they're like the
criminal guys right I mean the ones that
like attack people and take what they
have and and so on and so forth there's
not really anything special about these
guys what is important about this
situation is that with as being
surrounded here this guy Guy starts to
use his powers and starts attacking
these guys and when he does that using
this God slap he just starts
annihilating these guys but he does it
in a way that seems to be on a much
grander scale than what Darius had done
so for those of you guys who follow like
Dragon Ball Z right this seems like the
equivalent of when Gohan loses his [ __ ]
any particular point in the anime and
just like just Manifest this extreme
level of power that nobody seemed to
know he had right a more pinpoint
example would be like during the rat at
Saga right where like he freaks out
because his dad's just getting
absolutely crushed right just because
Goku's being taken to the Woodshed by
Raditz and so Gohan just like freaks out
and attacks the guy just gives him like
the head butt from hell but it's just
like holy cow this guy's got some power
but how deep does this power go that
kind of thing right which is cool
because there's like this amazing full
page Splash which honestly it's it's
cool the way it's done it's just like
boom right and just like all these guys
are seemingly taken out in one Fell
Swoop now here's the other thing that I
also want to point out here is something
that I was kind of waiting to this point
to talk about as you guys can tell with
the exception of like the blood itself
and a few things here and there the
comic is largely done in black and white
the way this art is done is beautiful
and the reason why is because with black
and white art you have to be very very
very careful if you're not too careful
and you have too much stuff going on in
a black and white comic it's very easy
to overwhelm the reader it's very easy
to put the reader in a place where they
just can't figure out what the hell is
going on when it comes to Art that's one
of the problems with like Liam Sharp's
art it's just it's so messy and all over
the place and none of it makes any sense
the way it's handled here by throwing in
little splashes of color it creates
depth and it makes it easy to
differentiate between different things
in the scene I love the way it's handled
the art is phenomenal by the way let's
just say that like I mean there are so
many panels in this comic that I kind of
want to just have like framed as a
picture in my in my office which I still
need to do a setup video where I show
you guys my whole basement comic book
setup place with all the Alex Ross art
and everything but the cool thing here
is that of course AES just kind of makes
his way off now he of course puts off
this idea that like Darius is going to
be pissed at him because he seemingly
destroyed his arm in the process so what
this seems to indicate is that as has
this power he doesn't really know how to
use it or at least use it in a way to
where he can keep himself protected and
disable whatever enemy he's facing off
against but in the middle of all this as
he's kind of walking along and just
collapses due to blood loss he's met by
a woman who is actually the daughter of
Dr Cyril now there is some complexity in
terms of their relationship that I
believe is covered in issues too and I
think the forthcoming issue three I'm
not sure if more is critical has
finished that one yet and is releasing
it but what ends up happening is because
of everything that's going on you
actually end up having a guy who
witnesses this whole situation with as
this guy races off to someone called the
defister who really kind of seems to be
sort of the criminal guy who runs all
the crime and all that kind of stuff
within Montpellier itself we're not
really given any information on this guy
truth to tell the way he's depicted by
just like torturing these guys and
literally just ripping them apart using
chains and so on and so forth that he
seems or really feels more like a
Kingpin type character but this guy is
really on the hunt seemingly for what
Darius has or what AIS has or whatever
the case happens to be instead we don't
really get a whole lot of indication
here instead that's really where the
comic ends that's where it kind of
concludes right like send them in to get
as and then of course extend my diving
board showing just kind of how
sociopathic this guy is he kills people
and then just kind of goes for a casual
swim but having said that this is issue
number one and I gotta tell you guys I
love it again there are a few things
that I would change but given the fact
that I'm not overly well versed in manga
and this comic is more rooted in manga
than it is like a Batman Superman type
of comic book it could be that I'm just
looking at it the wrong way but let me
know what you guys think down in the
comment section make sure you guys check
out the link to the campaign down in the
description and I will catch you on
later peace